اليوم ، وبطريقة من الحزبين ،
أظهر المنزل أنه لا يوجد أحد فوق
القانون
ولا حتى رئيس الولايات المتحدة
أن دونالد ترامب يمثل خطرًا واضحًا
وقائمًا على
بلدنا وأننا مرة أخرى كرمنا يمين
المنصب لحماية والدفاع عن
دستور الولايات المتحدة فساعدنا الله
الآن أنا
حزين وبقلبها ينكسر بسبب ما يعنيه هذا
لبلدنا رئيس سيشهد
تمردًا
سيوقع على
مقالة عزل
أه ويصدق على مشروع القانون لجعله
رسميًا  مقال إقالة أه بعنوان
التحريض
على التمرد هناك تراه
هناك ، لذا فهو صفقة منتهية
بقدر ما يهتم مجلس النواب
بأن الوثيقة
الآن ستقدم رسميًا إلى
مجلس الشيوخ الأمريكي
حيث ستكون هناك محاكمة وليس من الواضح
متى الوثيقة  سيتم إرسالها إلى
المنزل
وليس من الواضح متى سيبدأ مجلس الشيوخ
المحاكمة بعد ذلك